Android - Performance Patterns
Layouts are the core
of how you create a modern,
beautiful Android application
for your users.
But if you're not careful,
your amazing layouts
can create a monster performance drain.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And if you're using fancy features
on your view layouts,
you might be getting into trouble.
Remember that any time the position
or size of an object changes
in the view hierarchy,
there may be ramifications
with respect to other layouts in the view.
For example, if a button
suddenly doubles in size,
a neighboring view may need to be moved.
And then, of course, the parent view
may need to be resized as a result.
There's a small set of properties
of a view that, when changed,
require the layout phase
of the rendering pipeline to occur
before updating the screen.
Basically this stage traverses
through the view hierarchy to calculate
the correct positions and sizes
for all views impacted by the change.
In general, this is
a reasonably fast process.
But if you're not paying attention,
you can trigger an expensive cascade
of layout operations, which can quickly
chip away at your frame time.
A perfect example of this
is the relative layout container.
Basically, this layout allows you
to define the position of a view
with respect to the position
of some other view in the hierarchy.
For example, always stay
to the right of the text box
or at the top of the current container,
or stay at the top of the topmost sibling,
but always to the right of
other siblings in my container.
Weird stuff like that.
The issue here is that in order
to properly position views
in relation to one another, a container
must kick off a second layout pass
before it can finalize positions
and move on to rendering.
Basically, it works like this.
The first pass will visit views and
calculate their positions and sizes
based upon their personal request.
The relative layout then uses this data
to figure out the proper positions
of correlated views or any weight sizes
and then makes
boundary adjustments accordingly.
At this point, a second layout pass
is kicked off to determine
the final positions to use for rendering.
The result, two full layout operations
through the children in the container
just to get things situated on the screen.
And the trick is this happens every time
a change happens in a relative layout.
But be warned here.
It's not the only container that
can produce this double layout behavior.
For example, linear layout generally
only issues a single layout request
until you add the measure
with largest child parameter,
in which case, it can end up needing
to kick off a second layout pass
to resolve the proper sizes.
A grid layout has a very similar issue.
This container allows relative positioning
but avoids the double taxation
by preprocessing the child view
relationships, which is great, right?
I mean, you get all the functionality
of a relative layout container
without any of the performance costs.
You get all the functionality.
This all gets thrown out the window
anytime the layout uses fill gravity,
or in some cases,
if weights are used in the wrong spots.
And then of course, you're
back into the same performance problem.
Now by themselves,
multiple layouts from these containers
won't be much of a performance burden.
But put them in the wrong spot,
and you'll end up with some big problems.
For example, any time there are
the root elements in your view hierarchy,
or when the container
has a deep view hierarchy beneath it,
or when there's lots of them
populating the screen like in a list view.
Basically, this problem can then compound
throughout the hierarchy.
Imagine a relative layout at the top
of your view hierarchy,
which will then do two layout passes.
And then later on,
you've got some list view below that
that has a cascade of grid layouts
inside of it.
Basically, the leaf nodes in this
configuration could end up having to do
a layout phase run on them
eight times each.
Obviously you've got better places that
you could be spending your frame time.
So looking to avoid the
plague of double layouts?
Here's a few helpful tips.
Firstly you can track down whether layouts
are eating into your frame rate
by taking a firm look
at the Systrace tool.
If you see that the measure/layout
portions of a rendering frame
are unusually high,
then there's a good chance
that it's eating into frame rate
in a bad way.
Secondly, take a swing at minimizing
the depth of your hierarchy.
See, sometimes double layouts
are simply unavoidable.
So reducing the amount of depth
in your view hierarchy
will help reduce the impact
they have on your general frame rate.
Thirdly, avoid calling layout requests
in any situations
where it's absolutely
not critical to do so.
When a view requests a layout, it's going
to trigger a layout in all of its parents.
Now although there's extensive caching
in this part of the system to try
to make this as fast as possible, it can
still be a very expensive operation.
Fourthly, watch the rest of the
Android Performance Patterns videos.
Fifthly, join the Google+ community and
ask questions to other performance gurus.
And twelfthly, keep calm,
profile your code,
and always remember,
perf matters.
(music playing)